And take a look.
This is the
face tonight of Alex Murdaugh.
Convicted killer is head
shaven in a South Carolina
prison system intake facility
on his way
within the next several weeks to serving
two consecutive life
sentences, life without parole
for murdering his wife, Maggie
and son Paul.
This is also the face of a man
whose family name was once synonymous
with the law
in the county
in South Carolina,
and that he lived in the scion
of multiple generations of Murdaugh's
in the legal,
professional and professional
and criminal justice system there.
At today's
hearing in the courthouse
where his grandfather's portrait
once hung, Murdaugh was sentenced.
He spoke briefly,
but Judge Clifton
Newman had the last word
I would never,
under any circumstances, hurt
my wife, Maggie,
and I would never under any circumstances
hurt my son Harper.
It might not have been you.
It might have been
the monster
you become when you
take 15, 20, 30, 40, 50, 60.
Opioid pills.
Maybe you become another person
Well, tonight, a primetime
exclusive interview
with Creighton Waters,
lead prosecutor in the case,
who made it plain in his remarks
today in court exactly
who Alex Murdaugh was to him.
No one who thought they were close to
this man knew who he really was.
And, Your Honor, that's chilling.
And I've looked in his eyes
and he liked to stare me down
because he would walk by me
during this trial and I could see
the real Alex Murdaugh
when he looked at me.
Mr.
Waters, thanks for joining us.
We just heard
you say that you knew Alex Murdaugh
was the killer.
As soon as you looked into his eyes
when you heard him today
continuing to declare his innocence,
I'm wondering what went through your mind
Nothing more than the same.
I think after he said
that, I'd got up
and said words
to the effect
of what more needs to be said.
You know,
the truth is not in this man
and I think that was a big part
of what
the jury saw and certainly a part of,
I believe, what
led them to the right verdict
that they reached
Were you surprised at all
by the speed of the jury's deliberations?
Well, I've always said that, you know,
trial lawyers
tend to be a little superstitious.
And I try, frankly,
not to think about things like that.
And people come up and talk to you
while you're waiting
and I'll say this, that
we had put so much out
there had been such a huge effort
by the whole team
and you saw the whole team in action.
I probably was less
nervous waiting for this verdict
than I ever had,
and not because of overconfidence,
but I just felt like we had done
all we can do.
But yes, it's usually when you get a
verdict within a short
period of time,
that's generally good for the state.
But, you know,
you never like to even consider that
until you actually hear
the word that you want to hear
this was obviously a very complex trial.
There was a lot of moving parts
to a lot of evidence was circumstantial.
One of the state's
key focuses
was that the timeline that night
and when you got up and you went through
all the things
that had would have had to have occurred
to have not been Alex Murdaugh,
I thought that was extraordinary.
And I just want to
play that for our viewers.
So what you're
telling this jury
is that it's a random vigilante
that just happened to know
that Paula Maggie
were both at Moselle on June 7th.
That knew that they would be
at the kennels alone on June
the seventh
and knew that she would not be there,
but only between the times of eight 49
and nono two,
that they show up without a weapon,
assuming that they're going
to find weapons and ammunition
there, that they commit this crime
during that short time window.
And then they travel
the same exact route
that you do
around the same time to Almeida.
That's what
you're trying to tell this jury.
You got a lot of factors in there, Mr.
Waters,
all of which I do not agree with,
but some of which I do.
It's interesting.
You know, obviously
that timeline was very crucial evidence.
And,
you know, it really tells a story
you know,
we have to remember,
this guy was a experienced lawyer doing
sometimes complex accident cases, cases.
He's a part time assistant solicitor,
and there's 100 years
of prosecution legacy in his family.
And so as we
started to look at that timeline,
it really appeared
that this was a man
who was manufacturing an alibi
and that these time
periods were more compressed
than seems reasonable.
You know,
and I think it's kind of ironic
that he was using his cell phone
in this kind of data
to construct an alibi.
But in the end,
that kind of video,
I think, really caught him.
But the chain of circumstances,
even though the burden is on the state,
the chain of circumstances
that he was trying
to get this jury to believe,
it just defied any sort of logic
that this could have occurred.
And I think it was compelling
to the jury.
Do you have any sense of
when he
came up with this decision
to kill his son and to kill his wife?
Because, as you said,
he was laying the groundwork
for this from, you know, that
I mean,
that day, earlier
that day at the very least.
Do you have any sense of how
long he had planned this
You know, one of the things I
described of him,
and this is why I think it was important
for the jury to hear this is the
I think I've used roller coaster
or hamster wheel
that he had been on for a decade.
And it's really,
you know, as you look at it
and look at it
in its entirety, it's really exhausting.
And these pressures were building.
They were coming to a culmination
and he was running out of options.
I think that
the other thing
that was very important to him
was this family legacy.
I think that was more important to him
than anything,
aside from his own personal
things that he would suffer
if all of this was exposed
when that exact moment was I don't know.
But I do know that all these pressures
I called it
a gathering storm,
a perfect storm
were arriving on June 7th.
And whether it was that day
or whether he'd been thinking about it
for a while,
I don't think we'll ever know.
There's
only one person who can answer that.
But what I do know
is that as those storms
as that storm arrived,
as he was running out of options,
as he was faced
with ruin of not just himself,
but again, that family legacy, as his son
had become a liability that
threatened to expose him.
That's
all those came to a head on June 7th,
and that's the day they died.
You also pointed out
just sort of the impunity that he
and maybe other members of his family,
some of his kids, maybe Paul,
but the impunity that he felt he had.
I mean,
it was
his great
grandfather, his grandfather,
his father had all been the prosecutors
in this area in South Carolina.
I mean, it seemed like
he figured he can do just about anything
Well, absolutely.
And that's what we
you know, I never knew him.
I did work with his father years ago
on a case.
But you know, with with Alex,
as we studied
this more
and more as the white collar
stuff, as we investigated
that over months
and months of investigation,
we really started
to get a picture of this man
in talking to the people
that that knew him
or thought they knew him,
because the one thing
it ultimately revealed
is no matter how close
the closest people in his life
had no idea who he was,
which I said was was chilling.
So as we started to discover
that, as we started to realize that,
you know, that became very,
very clear and very apparent
that he had never faced
accountability in his life
and had always been able to escape that
and that that was more important to him
than anything.
That's why
I was always convinced
that he would testify in this case,
that he was assured
that he could talk his way out of it
one more time,
maybe not out of all the trouble,
but certainly talk his way out of this.
Obviously, the jury saw otherwise.
He said that even today in the
in the court was
I would never do anything to hurt
Maggie or Paul.
Paul, Paul.
He said today,
which obviously he was talking
about the murder, but he he was
I mean,
he hurt them repeatedly for
I mean, he was stealing money.
I mean, he was ruining their lives.
He was a distant father
because he was a drug addict
who had been lying to everybody.
And was stealing
from all of these people.
The idea that he hadn't
already hurt them,
even without killing them, is
just another lie.
Yeah.
And again, I'm not a psychologist
and I'm not trying
to diagnose anyone here.
But, you know,
I think there's an element
of narcissism there.
I think that to to some extent,
you know,
he he almost saw this
as a necessary action
so that they wouldn't
have to suffer
the consequences
of of any of this coming out.
But I think he's very careful
in how he says things. He's a lawyer.
And his cross-examination
was very interesting
in dealing with them.
You know, one of the things
I wanted to do,
unlike a typical cross where you
you really try to control
the conversation, is to start
with a constructive cross
and get him talking, because I felt like,
you know,
he believed he could look at that jury
and really convince them.
But I felt if I got him
talking, he would eventually
you know, he would
eventually lie
and they would get to see that
in real time, see that in action.
But I think
also they got frustrated
by kind of the things you're saying.
You know, if you really listen to
what he's saying,
you know, it's very careful
in how he words it.
You know, he says he never hurt them.
You know, at one point
he said
and he never, quote, intentionally
hurt them.
You know, a lot of times
people try to to,
you know,
live with the things they've done
by, you know,
qualifying it or say
that wasn't the real money
or things like that.
He had a very well known in common
tell that whether it was on the videos
of the law enforcement interviews
or even on the stand,
that when he said things that are a lie,
he would shake his head forward like this
while he's doing that.
Is that right?
These were all things that some
grand jury of course. Yeah.
Yeah.
And so,
you know, and
I pointed that out to the jury,
but I think the main thing was,
you know,
establishing with them
that nobody who knew this man
knew who he really was.
He lies effortlessly.
He lies convincingly.
And he looked in their eyes
and lied to them about
perhaps the most important fact
of this whole case,
you know, about
when is the last time he saw
his wife and his son alive
and only when he was back into yet
another corner
did he come up with this latest version.
And obviously, the jury saw through that.
And I think,
you know, he got up there very,
very confident that he was going to
you know, this is his community
and he's always been able to do this,
that he was going to,
you know, get them on his side.